bei einigen menschen sollen diese
aufnahmen eine gänsehaut erzeugen die
vom kopf startet und dann angenehm den
rücken entlang läuft genannt wird das
phänomen autonomes sensory meridian
response und gilt als beruhigendes
gefühl das unter anderem durch visuelle
und akustische sinnesreizen ausgelöst
wird die autorin der filmaufnahmen heißt
laura disco und hat sich auf diese art
von nahaufnahmen spezialisiert dabei
schneidet die us-amerikanerin mit einer
zuvor stark erhitzten messerklinge durch
die mit glitter angereichertem
wackelpudding auf instagram wurden
bereits mehrere videos hochgeladen
einige davon wurden über 2,6 millionen
mal angeschaut